you know in your pantry you have all these
spices and herbs you want to make sure that
they last as long as possible so in this video
i'm going to talk about the expiration date
on spices and herbs so with spices you usually
have different blends of dried roots bark or the
stem and usually spices last anywhere between
two and three years then you have herbs which
are the dried leaves like basil oregano thyme
rosemary mint bay leaves dill parsley cilantro
sage and typically they will last anywhere between
one and three years but then we have the whole
spices as in whole peppercorn coriander
mustard seeds fennel seeds caraway seeds
cumin seeds clove and cinnamon sticks which lasts
four years or even longer so you might want to
consider getting most of your herbs in a whole
form and then just get a grinder now what happens
when these herbs have an expired expiration date
well they're still okay to take they just might
lose flavor potency and color but they're not
going to make you sick unless they have gotten
some moisture and there's some mold growing in
that product now i know in my pantry i probably
have herbs still in there from maybe seven even
10 years ago we still use them on occasion but
they're just not as strong now when you're storing
herbs make sure they're in glass sealed bottles
with the top really tight because air moisture and
light can degrade these herbs a lot faster make
sure they're in a dark place and make sure they're
not exposed to heat so you wouldn't want to store
them right by the oven now if you have oil seeds
like in sesame seeds poppy seeds i would recommend
refrigerating those because the oils do turn
rancid a little bit faster so anyway i just wanted
to do this video to answer someone's question
on the expiration date on spices and herbs so
if you're enjoying my content which i hope you are
and you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i would really appreciate
you sharing your success story so click the link
down below to my website where you can upload
your success story so you can help inspire others